the fight is done
we lost
[Music]
stay hidden
you and last time i saw you uh
i don't spend a lot of time talking
about this but you told me that you
dressed up as a tomato like for some
commercial yeah i didn't believe you and
when you look it up
[Laughter]
i have a driver a guy drives me in
london called lee when i'm working in
london
and he
tapes he i always forget but he's taped
the image of me as the tomato inside the
the sun visor so whenever i put the sun
visor down on the way to work there i am
as a tomato and i'm like oh come on lee
he still does it to this day i'm gonna
do that too on my computer listen i am a
major prequelist so this is very surreal
for me that's cool to talk to you right
now is it surreal for you and with all
the recent reboots we've seen in all
these years did it cross your mind that
you would one day reprise your role as
obi-wan kenobi it's been a slow burn
really to be honest
i wouldn't have wanted to do it
you know in 2003 when we finished the
last
episode that i did um revenge of the
sith they were so technical to make and
there was so much blue screen and green
screen they were quite difficult to do
those films um but we did our best and i
think they
when they came out they also weren't
they didn't appear to be very well
received by their critics and um so we
were left as the cast
feeling a little bit sorry for ourselves
after they came out you know after
getting into star wars and and it being
such a huge deal for them to be sort of
slightly pooh-poohed by the critics was
hard and it's taken years to realize
that in actual fact the generation we
made them for the kids
who we made them for really love them
you know and um i didn't realize for a
long time that that was the case and now
i'm discovering that and feeling that
more every day it's a really nice
feeling and uh that's definitely partly
one of the reasons why i wanted to come
back to play him again and uh
i'm really happy that i did i really
enjoyed it like i really enjoyed playing
him again i'm that bit closer to obi-wan
to alec guinness at age and
um i'm always trying to sort of play my
obi-wan kenobi
so that he grows up to be alec guinness
you know and uh that was maybe even
easier this time
how did you find obi-wan's voice again
because you mentioned alec guinness and
a lot of fans are saying that you
actually sound a lot more like alec
i just i just um yeah i think
i'm always trying to sound like him
in my head and i don't want to do an
impersonation of him but i but i have to
feel like him and
it's it's the way he phrases things
and i just i just
i just listened to him a lot you know
and i i have all his lines from a new
hope in a sound file just to just his
lines just sort of odd to listen to but
it
there's a particular
i could do takes in this that were
more like me and then there were some
that were definitely more alec guinness
he takes you know
and
i don't know there are some lines in the
trailer that are quite alex gonna see
it's true
it's fascinating i'm just picturing you
opening up your file on your phone and
every morning editing to alec guinness
voice hello there yes
yes fun
i can't believe you just said hello
there that's what i've ever wanted
everyone's excited to see you and hayden
reunite i was reading that you guys
actually met before you started shooting
which i think is really cool what was it
like to be with hayden christensen on
set in this show and see him as darth
vader
amazing i mean just amazing experience
to be we've been shooting for a little
while before
uh hayden's first day and i was on set i
couldn't
believe how many people were around like
there was all of our crew were hanging
around behind the cameras and i was
thinking that's odd it's not
it's not usually this many people around
and then
hayden walks out in the vader suit and
i'm like oh of course there we are
everyone everyone
wherever he went on set there was like
a polite distance a polite-ish distance
there were many many people you know the
love that the
fans have for hayden is is huge you know
from the prequels and and so many of our
crew were in fact star wars fans you
know so it was just really electric
whenever he was on and and
i can't talk about what we what we do in
the series together but you'll see and
it was special to shoot for sure
can you at least tell me the first thing
you guys said to each other when you saw
each other's obi-wan and darth we hugged
a lot you know like it was um
it wasn't necessarily you know we're
like really we got very close making
those first movies we were in he was in
episode two and three and we were
shooting them
in sydney australia so we were really
far away from home and we had so much
time together in the fight you know the
fight gym working on the fights together
shooting together and then because we
were away from home we spent a lot of
time outside of work together as well he
was very sweet with my my eldest
daughter clara for sure had her first
she totally fell in love with it she was
four years old but she definitely fell
in love with hayden and he was so sweet
with her you know it was really lovely
with her
and um
i've always i've always loved that he
just gave her a lot of time and
he's a lovely lovely man so it was just
great to see him again and when we
walked out as you know
anakin vader
obi-wan kenobi it was it was a moment it
was a moment on set and uh
it was it was like no time had passed at
all since the since 2003.
it makes me so happy i also love you and
how much of your family like you
mentioned your daughter but now your
wife is going to be an ahsoka tano your
uncle was wedge antilles it's just
amazing but something that uh i've
always wanted to ask you is i i just
find you to be so hilarious like you
make me laugh so much i watch so many of
your interviews and obi-wan has always
been sort of more straightforward and i
was wondering what is that like to play
for you do you ever joke on set and you
want to like throw it in front of your
alliances
well i i always think that i think that
alec guinness is quite witty but it's
quite it's quite behind the eyes he's
always got a sort of twinkle in his eyes
you know
and so i sort of try and do as obi-wan i
do i do have some sort of
snidey lines with with hayden in the in
the prequels where i'm you know some
sort of sarcastic humor with him i guess
i think you can see in some of the sort
of behind-the-scenes stuff or the um
some of the memes are very funny because
you know when you take out
there's just some funny moments i'm just
thinking there's a funny one where i'm
standing in the door i'm standing in the
doorway of a spaceship looking at him
and it just looks very camp and funny
you know the way i'm looking down at him
there's some very amusing memes for from
the prequels you are the best meme ever
can i get them may the force be with you
me may the force be with you
there you go
you were the greatest thank you
ever and i'm so happy that you love
you're taking fan sentiment to heart now
because the prequels are everything for
me oh well that's lovely to you i just
didn't know for a long time i didn't
know
i didn't i think we always concentrate
on the bad and never like the positive
you know yeah also there's just no
social media there was no also the kids
were kids they weren't there was no way
to know what people felt about them
really and um and that now that that i
hear it loud and clear and i'm delighted
you can't write all we
[Music]
love you in the queen's gambit and now
the fact that you're an action figure
like i i'm so happy for you thank you so
much
this is so wild i'm a major fan of the
prequels so i first wanted to know what
was it like seeing hayden christensen
and ewan mcgregor back in star wars and
what did it feel like to be in scenes
with them
um
wild
wild you know we only get to do
uh what we're doing right now because of
the foundation that they laid nearly 20
years ago
and um it's it's really
invaluable to be able to stand in
between them and soak up all the wisdom
from them that i can
and we work with so many people who were
excuse me lifelong star wars fans
and it was beautiful to sort of watch
people live out their dreams on set with
these you know
cultural pillars i would say
so was there a moment for you that was
like defining where you're like wow i'm
in a star wars series right now
oh so many so so many um and i wish i
could i wish i could like say say but
um i think the closer we get to it
belonging to the people the
the more real it gets i would say on
that end for sure well that just got me
really excited
um i'm super stoked to get to know more
about your character riva obviously i
know she's an inquisitor and i was
wondering what can you tell us about the
inquisitors and also did you look to
star wars rebels or star wars jedi
fallen order video games for inspiration
she's on a team she's on a team of
inquisitors um you know and any team is
full of individuals and she has her own
way of doing things and she doesn't care
you know what anybody thinks about the
way in which she does them and um
i didn't i didn't look to the other
lore it was important for me i feel
really blessed coming in because there's
not
so much about her you know she's new and
so i was able to you know bring
what i felt to it which was really great
um and
yeah well we got to talk about because
obviously we're going to get to know
your character more and everything that
you're bringing to her because there's
not much we know about her but one thing
that we did see in the trailer that got
me excited moses is there's a part where
in the trailer i think it's your voice
where you say you can't run obi-wan and
you see you bust out this lightsaber and
you're just like you just look so cool
i have to know about you know
riva's lightsaber saga like did you get
to pick out your own i know ewan did and
samuel jackson requested his own purple
one tell me about picking your
lightsaber and and what her lightsaber
is like
um
you know so i didn't get to pick my
lightsaber but
my lightsaber is custom to myself and my
hands which is really cool um you know
and it went through a lot of processes
as we went through and training you know
learning what needs to change about the
lightsaber as we go and it really is
something when you get to set and you
know they open up the box and you get to
fight with yours for the first time
yeah it's pretty sick it's pretty sick
what was it like fighting with it for
the first time oh well i mean the
training is like it's it's really in
depth we trained for
four months before we even got to set
you know and it takes so much
um time and like so many little muscles
that you would never even think of
um and it's hard at first but once you
get it you feel super confident and
um i think the surprise in fighting with
it for the first time was like um there
are different size lightsabers for
depending on which kind of scene you're
shooting and there's the full length one
and then there's a medium one and
there's like a little bitty baby one too
so you use all of them which is really
cool that's so cool i had no idea so
then were you able to like take home the
little one and practice at home or would
you use something else to practice with
um so i did have a practice saver that i
was sent home with
that i still have or my best friend has
i think right now um
and
i do i have my hilt hanging in my living
room so i have the hilt of my savory my
living
that is so sick that's so cool one thing
i've always wondered to moses that i've
always wanted to ask an actor in a star
wars anything is i feel like the
characters in star wars speak a little
differently it's almost like their
pacing is a little slower and more
intentional i was wondering is there
some type of jedi training that you go
through to be you know to play a star
wars character and
specifically about the voice too i was
curious
um well the voice
i'm not really sure
but i know that i know with you and he
when he started he sort of focused on
alec guinness but for me
um i think it's also because it's
heightened text
in a way like it's it's real but it's
like also like
lifted it kind of makes me think of uh
shakespeare a little bit in a way i
don't know if that makes sense or not
but
um
yeah i missed the last part of your
question i'm sorry no that's okay you
kind of answered it
i also wanted to know before i go thank
you for that answer
is now that you're in star wars is there
any other star wars character that you
would love for riva to interact with
ahsoka
yeah yeah she's really cool
um and i'm excited to see that series as
well
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail
the jedi code is like an itch
he cannot help it
where is he
deborah it is such a pleasure to share
space with you congratulations on like
this
major major accomplishment i'm like a
huge prequelist
that's awesome
this is like so cool for me i'm also
just a major fan we all are of your
directing work you know on better call
saul and the mandalorian
the mandalorian is very much a western
the book of boba fett is a mob story i
wanted to know what kind of story is
obi-wan kenobi um yeah i mean i think
for star wars for me the dna is always
in westerns and in samurai films and i
think
um you know i think the difference
from mandalorian to kenobi for me was
like if i was looking at references of
classic westerns um or classic samurai
films for mandalorian
for kenobi i was looking because we
wanted to do a story that was much more
character-based i was looking at things
that were a little bit more atmospheric
a little more poetic emotional so i was
looking at things like the proposition
assassination of jesse james where it's
still a western and you still have the
genre but it feels a little different in
the point of view
i can't wait to go watch those now
thanks for sharing
that's awesome
uh what's really interesting about the
fact that you directed better call saul
is that in that show the characters very
much gradually moved to the dark side
too
so my team and i were wondering you know
what is so alluring about the dark side
and what have you learned about the dark
side now working on both of those shows
and the power of it
um it's funny because i've done a lot of
genre and i really truly love doing
fantasy and sci-fi and i really seek it
out to do it um and there's a lot of
darkness in it i guess because it's
always you know you're an apocalypse or
zombies or something going on so it's
sort of natural that it comes with
darkness
um i think it's you know it's
interesting to explore because it's just
it's so part of human nature you know
and it's very basic but just kind of you
know the star wars of it all of
lightside darkside it is so embedded in
just human nature that it is something i
think that it's just a natural fit
honestly for storytelling
i love that and i love that you got to
explore that but yeah it's true let's
talk about the light side for a second
because you know i was telling you i
obviously love the prequels and whether
people love them or not what i found in
conversations and arguments
is uh everyone can agree on you and
mcgregor's performance as obi-wan kenobi
what what is it about euan's take on
obi-wan kenobi that you think is so
special to fans
um i know for me i think
you know ewan just brings such a warmth
and he brings such a
humor and a compassion to the role you
know like he does that thing where he
smiles with his eyes and like there's
just such a sensitivity and a depth to
the character um that it's it's very
hard not to love it and it it's so
interesting because you know also as
we've started to do press and the
trailer came out just feeling like that
prequel love and you know
you know people like you you who
genuinely like grew up with them and
love them that you know i feel like for
that generation like ewan really is
their obi-wan kenobi uh so it's you know
i think for a lot of us it's like
he just represents the best qualities of
the jedi
it's so true it's like you want him to
be your uncle or something yeah
i'm so excited to obviously see him and
hayden in this show but i'm also super
excited about another character i'm a
major fast and furious fan i love sun
kang i feel like a lot of people aren't
talking about i know you're the first
person who's asked me about sun kang
yeah
i'm so proud of myself right now can you
tell me about casting him what what can
you tell us about his character and
working with him
um sung is awesome and honestly like i
was so fortunate with this cast i had a
great cast everybody was so cool to work
with and he's also a big star wars fan
and also you know obviously the
connection to han solo um so
it was great to have him come and be
part of it and you know he's obviously
playing fifth brother which is coming
out of rebels as you know one of the
characters that dave established um and
it's an interesting character because
you know there has been obviously stuff
that's been established with him but
there was also a fair amount of room for
sung to try to make the character his
own
um so i think it was it was awesome it
was kind of great having someone like
sun come in and really make that role
his
i can't wait to see the magic that you
guys make together with that i'm very
very much looking forward to that as
well as of course easter eggs
what can you tell us when it comes what
can you tell us about easter eggs in
this show and what are you most excited
for people to see when it comes to that
um you know i don't think it would be
star wars if we didn't have some easter
eggs and we didn't have some cameos so
there there definitely are some to come
um you know and i think for us like
for us like what we do have in the show
it needed to come out of character and
story for us we didn't want to just put
things in for the sake of it um but that
said obi-wan kenobi is a character that
has definitely interacted with a lot of
people and has done a lot in his life
okay well
i'm just gonna for the record if jar jar
or mace windu show up
that would actually die
um deborah i'm so excited to see your
work on this is there is a star wars
film something that you would love to
explore in the future like is that
something that you're sort of thinking
about and want to do bucket list wise um
i think at this point you know obviously
i've done three years on kenobi and you
know did mandalorian right before this
at this point honestly all i'm looking
forward to is actually just taking a
vacation and taking a break
um so i honestly can't fathom anything
right now i just i just kind of need to
have a rest for a second um but that
said you know it's an amazing galaxy
it's a tremendous place to direct in
it's so fun
um and there's so many stories i think
that could still be told in this galaxy
so
absolutely also i commend you for saying
that because burnout is so real oh yeah
i'm ready i don't think your penis is a
badge of honor and yes you have given
enough to the world so um
congratulations on this do you i would
love your take just personally on um if
you would love to see a darth vader
spin-off series come out of this
um i don't know you know because with
vader i feel like less is always more
and it's you're always in danger and
that's something that you know we really
kept a close eye on is that so much of
his power comes from
less and you know from keeping that
mystique with him so i guess it would
depend on how it was done
okay i i like that answer too yeah it's
true that's that's a character we have
to protect what was it like for you i i
was just talking to you and about this
what was it like for you
to see
um hayden walk out as darth and you in
as obi-wan on set for the first time i
would love to know what you were feeling
like in those moments and and if you
could just sort of describe that moment
yeah you know i think with both of them
and you know obviously they started at
different times so um
you know seeing you know the first time
i saw ewan in character was it a camera
test very early on and just seeing him
sort of back in the robes and walking
out like for me i really did have a
moment where i was like that's the show
you know i mean like this is the show
like and it's obi-wan kenobi standing in
front of me um you know with hayden
you know it's just such an intense thing
vader you know like he's one of the most
iconic characters in cinematic history
uh he's also twice my size you know so
it's it's a very intense thing so you
definitely have a moment the first time
you see it um and then once you know
after that then you're like you got to
get back to work and you just kind of
got to focus and go but yeah it was
incredibly special
you